let's try our caller from the 705 area
code we will try that caller from 705
let me know your name where you're
calling from and what's on your mind
today
hello this is Peter calls from Ontario
Canada and I have a question here I'm
wondering if there's a chance that you
can abolish vegan extremists producer
path from the show and possibly bring
back good old Louis now why would you
want that to happen all just wondering
if there's a chance well but it let them
answer the question of if you wanted it
to happen or if you didn't might
influence whether there's a chance of
that I mean is that something that you
would see favorably or unfavorably
probably favored Lou okay
there's really no chance of that I mean
Louis does not live in Boston Louis has
relinquished his position here Pat now
is employed here and he is the producer
and there's no reason why that would
happen I could see with you know the
keurig scandal or the cast scandal or
the middle name controversy right maybe
you want me outside is there anyone in
particular well he called you a vegan
extremist so Peter is it because of
Pat's veganism that you would want him
out like his veganism unsuited for the
David Pakman show or I think it's a
combination of the veganism and all the
scandals going on right so she's fair
enough all right well listen we thought
that he had weathered the scandal sort
of I hear they could potentially bring
me down yeah that was always a
possibility I think that I still believe
the keurig scandal is the worst but all
right Peter we'll keep you posted buddy
thank you so much appreciate the call
and yeah that's that's something got
something else